ein feuerball über dem ukrainischen akw
sapori europas größtes atomkraftwerk im
südosten des landes ukrainische behörden
sprechen von schweren beschuss durch
russische truppen
verzweifelter hilferuf des kraftwerks
sprechers in der nacht
streitkräfte der russischen föderation
feuern auf das atomkraftwerk subotic es
besteht die reale gefahr einer nuklearen
bedrohung des größten atomkraftwerks in
europa wir fordern dass der beschuss der
reaktorblöcke des atomkraftwerks mit
schweren waffen eingestellt wird
doch die angriffe auf das akw gehen erst
einmal weiter inzwischen soll das feuer
allerdings gelöscht sein die
geschehnisse in der nacht wecken bei
vielen beunruhigende erinnerungen an den
26 april 1986 tschernobyl im norden der
heutigen ukraine um 123 kommt es zum gau
dem größten anzunehmenden unfall
offenbar handelt es sich um das bisher
schwerste unglück in der geschichte der
atomreaktoren der wahrscheinlich am
samstag in brand geratene reaktorkern
ist offenbar weiter außer kontrolle
ausgerechnet die simulation eines
stromausfalls geht schief in
reaktorblock 4 fallen plötzlich die
turbinen aus kühl wassermangel die
ersten rohre bersten eine explosion
zerstört die tonnen schwere abdeckung
des reaktors die aktives material wird
in die atmosphäre geschleudert
das ganze unglück wird erst am nächsten
tag deutlich
soldaten werden in das feuer gejagt ohne
ausreichend geschützt zu sein die
meisten bezahlen diesen einsatz mit
ihrem leben die führung der sowjetunion
versucht noch das ausmaß der katastrophe
zu verheimlichen
bis es nicht mehr anders geht
bei dem beschlossenen akw das vergangene
nacht den sabrina brannte vorerst
entwarnung laut behörden wurde bisher
keine erhöhte strahlung festgestellt
zugeschaltet aus darmstadt ist uns dr
christoph pistner vom öko-institut
experte für nukleare technologien und
bereichsleiter nukleartechnik herr
doktor pistner viele haben wohl heute
früh erst mal an tschernobyl gedacht wir
haben den beitrag gesehen 1986
ja in der tat kommen einem die
erinnerungen sowohl in tschernobyl als
auch an den schweren unfall in fukushima
es ist denke ich historisch beispiellos
dass wir bilder sehen von einem
militärischen angriff um eine
kerntechnische anlage herum aber auch
auf eine kerntechnische anlage und das
weckt natürlich sehr große sorgen auch
für eskalation szenarien
erstmal das war der letzte satz im
beitrag entwarnung dennoch das ist ja
nicht das einzige atomkraftwerk in der
ukraine insgesamt gibt es 15 reaktoren
welche bedeutung könnten diese standorte
für die weitere entwicklung dieses
krieges haben
erstmal entwarnung ist richtig die
anlage scheint nach angaben die wir auch
über die eu gehört haben nicht umgehbar
soweit verbunden zu sein dass wir mit
einem unmittelbaren eskalation weiter
rechnen müssen aber es ist natürlich
beispiellos dass wir wirklich einen
militärischen angriff auf dem
kraftwerksgelände sehen das betrifft uns
zunächst die beiden anlagen im winter
ukraine bei weiteren verlauf des krieges
können aber natürlich auch anlagen
gelände im norden der ukraine betroffen
seien aber auch unabhängig vom konkreten
angriffen muss man sagen ist eben eine
kriegerische situation in einem land für
die sicherheit der kernkraftwerke sehr
gefährlich bereits ein großflächiger
stromausfall durchaus ja auch durch
militärische handlung verursacht werden
könnte kann zu einer eskalation der
sicherheit führen die frage
betriebspersonal
ist das vorhanden kann es die anlage
erreichen können wir der anlage notfall
erreichen da stellen sich also noch sehr
sehr viele frauen
jetzt hat sogar china vor einer solchen
eskalation gewarnt wie kann man denn die
sicherheit an solchen anlagen überhaupt
gewährleisten gerade jetzt im krieg
zunächst mal muss eigentlich allen
beteiligten parteien klar seien
militärisch konflikt den unmittelbare
umgebung um ein kernkraftwerk darf es
nicht geben darauf muss unbedingt
verzichtet werden beide kriegsparteien
müssen sicherstellen dass eine externe
stromversorgung der anlagen dauerhaft
sichergestellt ist das personal auf die
anlage kommen kann unterstützungskräfte
auf die anlage kommen können das auch
technische hilfsmittel auf die anlage
kommen können nur dann ist ein betrieb
dieser anlagen eine sicherung dieser
anlagen auch dauerhaft möglich
danke für diese einschätzung nach
darmstadt dr christoph pistner war das
zu dem atomkraftwerk in der ukraine auf
dessen gelände ist nach einem
bombenangriff gebrannt hat